*From game* "Return the slaaaab, or suffer my cuuurssse"
Ah!
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to a few horror games.
Now, we're starting off with one called
Courage's Curse, which if you remember Courage The Cowardly Dog
you might remember that there was a
being that didn't like Eustace having that slab, and Eustace didn't want to return said slab
But I don't remember Muriel being all demonic and evil over there in the corner
*sniff*
So we're gonna get through a few horror games today and we're starting off with this one
because I couldn't resist
*Chuckles*
I love Courage The Cowardly Dog
I've never- I- I've - I think maybe once I've played a game
about Courage The Cowardly Dog but that was about it.
"Once Eustace obtained the slab, he decided to bury it in his basement
"to prevent anyone from stealing it but King Ramses was not happy about this, he's now out for blood
"and will do whatever it takes to get back his slab
"even if it means possessing Muriel to find the slab and kill anyone who gets in Muriel's or his way.."
Is that what happened?  I don't remember. Poor Muriel. Muriel no! Please! I'm just a-
*Spooked Markimoo*
Ooh
I'm just an innocent little dog I thiiiink.
yes I am
retrieve King Ramse- Oh
*A spooked Mark has appeared!*
What the- *chuckles* wha- wh- wa
wai- wait a minute. Wait a minute! Wait a minute
hehehe....Umm..
I'm unsure about that face.
Is that you Eustace? Eustace is that- is that you?
Stupid dog! Okay, I'm assuming that's you.
It was just weird
waking up next to Eustace but I guess it's okay that uh.. You know, a dog can sleep on the bed it was
just ME
waking up next to Eustace that was a bit shocking. Oh this looks good
*more chuckling*
*confused boi*
Hi? hello? who's there?
Oh gosh, oh. Oh no *small laugh*
"Return the slaaab..."
I'm sorry! I'm getting to it! "Return the slaaab" shut up
I'm working on it
Oh my gosh, I think the only time that I've ever played anything Courage The Cowardly Dog related was when I played like a Gmod map-
*Computer Beeps*
"Do you have the code for the padlock attached to the basemont door?"
No I don't
UH?
Well, that's a problem-
*Spoopy Noises*
HEEY!
WHAT THE HELL?!
HEY! HEY! HEY!
stop that! I can make weird noises too!
*Weird Noises from Markimoo*
Okay, all right. Theenk you. Oh, something printed out
I dunno what it is... It's somethin'....
I got the code.
OH! HI! MURIEL!
WELL THAT'S A PROBLEM
WOAH! HEY WOAH!
AAAAH ALRIGHT! Sorry! I'm sorry! This is so stupid. AAAAAH!
I got the code!
Oh, where are we goi- Oh shit!
Oh. Oh. Muriel?
What the fuck?
*Doors closing*
*Ghost Piano*
Kayy?!
WOAH! Okay. Alright. Sorry! *Chuckles*
I didn't know what I was doin'
I got, the code! How do I get outside? uuhhh
I mean how do I get downstairs? I just got- "Return the slaaab"
I don't wanna. Is this it?
*DUN NUH NUH*
It's locked. I need to find a key to remove it. Okay, so I got the code but I need a key
well, shitty dicks. Alrighty then
Muriel?
Food? Water? Nothing.
Ah! WOAH!
Open! AIE! sorry! Hi Muriel you- *laughs*
Ah, shit! sorry,
*Nervous chuckling*
Oh, that's not right either! UMM
Okay well we've got a lot of problems and I don't know what to do about it, I think I need to
maybe I can use the ca- WHAT?!?!
Maybe I can use the car to bust down the door?
EEEH
I guess that's a logical conclusion? okay
Oh god. I gotta find the car keys first, okaaay. aaaalright
Here we go, where the frick are the car keys?
Ah, shit that's not good all right
umm
okay all right
ah...
*fart*
here
AHH WEEWEEWEEWOO
WOAH WAOH!
MURIEL! MURIEL! MURIEL!
W-uh oh....AAH
Hi
Hello, how are you doing?
You are just delightful
Please stop, I'm already suffering your curse, stOp
Alright, here we go
nope that's not a goo-
AAAHH! Oh
fu ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha haa
*Laughs*
ah so stupid. What's in here?
Uh oh, well that's not good
*does this boy ever stop laughing?*
This game is a goddamn- I found nothing
You're goddamn right I found nothing I am a useless piece of garbage *No you're not Mark*
Oh boy
I found car keys!
Didn't expect to find that on the first go! Okay let me get the code printing and then I can come back for it maybe
Probably not but-
*Computer Beeps*
Okay do you have the code all right so I got that, working on that I just need to go downstairs
slam the car- AH! I'm sorry, excuse you Muriel
Alri-hi-hi-hight?
What's over here?
Nothing. Whole lotta- Oh
s'what's uhh
Well  I already got the keys why do I need to look anymore? Uh oh
Yeah, why am I still looking? I don't need to look, I got lucky
okay. can I jump? okay..
Muriel?
Please don't
Got a code
Alright, got a code. Where's Muriel?
Muriel?
if you club me in the back of the head with your rolling pin again, I'm gonna be veeery upset
AH WHY? OH UH THAT'S Not good. Okay, alright. WEeLL
Okay, EUH. alright *muttering*
A BRICK TO LAY?!
BUT I HAVE THE- OEUGH
*Poor Mark* I don't have a brick to lay
I could shit a brick, that'd probably help right? Probably not
Okay, well
Okay
I don't know what you want from me
I Know you want that slab from me, but i'm just looking for-
Oh, hi
*Giggles*
I'm sorry
Pardonez moi.
Okay, is there anything in this goddamn cornfield. No
wait, maybe there is, maybe there's a brick in the cornfield
OOOOH, I need to find a sho- okay
It's all adding up it's all adding up I'm really getting it up in my brain
Oh HU HU HU HU HU
Someone's an eager beaver. Do I  really gotta go search the cabinets for a brick? Oh.. that's not good
Oh that's- That's probably not good
I found nothing, okay I don't think I'm gonna find a brick in here.
Guys?
*DUN NUH NUH*
I found a- *laughs* I found a brick!
Hey, I was wrong, I totally found a brick
He didn't notice me. The idiot
*Sly laughter*
Well aren't you dumb as a brick? And I just happened to also, have a brick
Uh oh
Uh...
Okay
Okay.
WOOSH
KABOOMIE
BANGIE
I got it okay well that's- that's problematic. Okay alright. Is it up here?
No, can't even go up there. There it is! There's a good boy!
Alright lemme wait for him to go by otherwise I'm
FUUUUUUUUCKED
*Nice singing*
'Kay, is he gonna go by? Yeah, okay
So I just gotta go dig up this bullshit, and then I got the code and then I got the key-
HEY! WHY?! MURIEL!
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO!
I'm not risking this! shit, fuck you Muriel! What are you doing outside?
You're not supposed to be out here!
Oh, come on!
Oh, well I'm double boned aren't I?
Oh titty sprinkles. No, not when I have everything!
WOAAH hey! How's it goin'there friend-o? OOHKAY
I don't wanna. I don't wanna suffer your- AAH! I don't wanna suffer your curse
okay, and now I just go out here
HEY!
MURIEL!
fUCkinG COME ON!
AAAAAAAAAAH!
oh, my god! That scared the puh-p-bu-pupeezies out of me oh
OH!
COME ONNNN!
Oh! I had everything!
I know I probably could have just gone for the cornfield, but I didn't know if it was gonna be like...
Sit me there for a- UUUAGH
Muriel?
"Return the slab..."
*Hi there*
AH! OH FUCKING! MURIEL!
GOD DAMN IT!
*Muttering and yelling as Mark tries to run from Muriel*
Fucking Muriel. Jeezums.
Close it (x1)
Close it (x2)
Close it (x3)
There we go, that's how you do it (x1)
That's how you do it (x2)
Okay, you stay up here for a bit, I gotta go, you know look around
I've got nothing, I don't have a key or a brick
I found nothing good, I was hoping for nothing and I found nothing
Great, now I don't have any expectations about myself
Uh oh, well that's- Okay, I found a brick!
AAAAH! I found a brick!
YAAAY!
Good?? I don't know where else to look
Okay there's Muriel, Muriel is coming back this way.
I don't know where slabby man is, but I'm open- Muriel just go upstairs.
Go upstairs Muriel. no that's not how.. No, Muriel please. Muriel! Oh my god
Muriel you are
Goddamn terrifying
Oh, I don't like you. Where's slabby man? Okay that's problem okay gonna risk this
*Laughter as Mark sneaks past Muriel
*Laughter from Mark because he has bested Muriel*
It's gotta be in here right? It's gotta be in here. If it's not in here... I'm boned
If i'm boned then i'm dead
Uh oh
*You're Boned*
I found nothing!? Found nothing but that's impossible it can't be nothing it's gotta be something oh that's okay well?
why is that interactable oh
here yes, why was that
I don't know what happened I found nothing- oh, hi, well. Oh wait, I vaguely remember you! *chuckle*
Okay, last place, I guess.
Mm-hmm! Always in the last- uh oh.
Murial, don't come in here! Muriel, no! Muriel, don't do-
*dun dun DUNN duunn*
Okay I think we're okay.
I can shove my head in the toilet if I'm if I'm not okay.
Oh... okay!
Okay, oh, Muriel! Howdy doody.  :)
That's not good. Okay. There's
slab man! Okay that's poifect.
Nooo!
Close the door and let's get to
rammin'! My favorite part of the dayy!
Rammin'- and then I'm just gonna take the shovel and I'm gonna go for the cornfield, cuz if if it stops me then I
mean, I guess there's just nothing to do anyway.
Oh shit, here he comes.  Oh no, no, no, nooo! (unenthusiatically)
Oh, shit.
Yeah, that's right, you better break off your chase.
Man, those clouds are a-whipping! Those are some ah-whipee-whoopee clouds!
Alright he gone.
Alright, he gone, I got my shovel.
Now, I'm gonna go dig in the cornfield.
*mutters incoherently*
Corn, key, corn cob key, here we go! Gimme coorn!
Give- uh oh, I gotta actually find it?
I thought- ooh, what is this?
Oh, THIS bullshit?? I got- see, this is why didn't just go for it!
'Cause- ohh, well i am... Oh!
It was there! Where are you? Okay, please tell me that- oh, oh, what am I- stop, oh!
Okay, where are you? I can't see shit. Ohh that's not good.
AAGH! OH NO, NO NOO! (watch out!)
I just got it!! I'm FIIINE!
GO AWAY!
OH COME OON! NOOO!
OHNO OHNO OHNO
Okay, I'ma lose him around the corner of the baaarn.
NOOOOOO!!
I WILL NOOOT!!
NNNO!
NOO! NO!
DON'T GO INSIDE! MURIEL, DON'T BE THERE!
WAAAAGH!
WAAAGH!
NOOO!
NOOOO I WAS RIGHT THERRRRE
HOW DID I LOSE THAAAT
It was right THEEERE
Fucking- come oooon maaaan!
God dammit, ugh.
God dammit, I should have just gone for it, I should have just gone for it. Why didn't I go for it? I'm a fucking idiot.
Oh, uh, oh. Found the car keys! Yes.
Aagh! What in the fuck- ohh, what the- Godddd,
(Mark groaning a lot)
What the fuck, what the fuuck, what the fuuck. (giggly)
Muriel, don't do that to me!
Miriam girl girl come on i don't trust like that muriel i don't trust like that i know you're coming?
Why don't you come along then?
i
Knew i knew i fuckin knew no
On that side of the door why is this so hard oh fuck
there she is there she okay i
See the tip okay alright then that's all okay all right see ya okay easy is that huh?
easy as that you think but maybe not
please i'm begging you murray murray murray more miller more oh
God i hope the brick isn't up there god damn it oh
i'm, fox found a bag okay we're good we're good we're good let's go slam this bitch let's go slam this bitch slam
that like button slam those comments
plan that bell
What have i become
Well that's not good okay that's a problem?
Yes, okay here we go here we go zips up loop no
No, no, no, no no don't. See me no no no don't
See me no don't do it don't they know i'm forging don't do it okay
So now i just have to get back in when muriel ain't there
Make, sense ooh
Make a sense up yeah i make a sense up okay anybody see muriel
get the slab where's the
slob get the slob get the swab that's a good slab
Now i got a return you can i please just go out this way oh no i can't okay
please muriel don't be right there muriel if you're oh
there's your fucking slab king ram fuck
The end oh?
The harrowing adventure
Harrowing on so many levels that's good
It looks so shit but luckily it worked for him some weird respect and also the nostalgia trip was very good there and also
fucking
like these two like these two and
eustace i thought you was eustace that got all buckled ducked over all right whatever
All right so that was fun but moving on to the next one okay so this one
this one's gonna be a big
shift in mood this one's called safety blanket
imagine you're good
and you were snuggled up under your blanket but you realize your blankets just not long enough to cover your feet and you know that
if you go to sleep and your feet are uncovered that's an
opportunity for the monster under your bed to grab you by your ankle and drag you down the abyss underneath my baby
Right make sense everyone knows this is true it's bedtime the monsters are out
To get you and your blanket it's just too small to cover your body
exactly what i just said
cover your exposed limbs to fend off the approaching tentacles the tentacles will only go for your feet hands and head
obviously they don't give a fuck about the body if the tentacles reach you it's game over survive until
mike what it oh my god what us
what, why are you sleeping whoa what are you what kind of shadow puppet
i mean the scariest thing i've never seen
I'm sorry it's not that money
Hurts this is just not at all what i expected i mean the image that i saw it was like this isn't
enticing in a way i guess but this
cover the cover your shame cover your shame hey hey i
Wish you was naked under here not that i'm not that i wish he was naked under here don't give me don't get me wrong
one is bad i
don't, see off the tutsis often pay off the good seas off the chrome dome hang-hang
Whoa whoa hey whoa get your oh my god?
Don't cry baby boy don't cry please oh?
gosh shit well
the night creeps really
Try that again yeah now that i know the proper stratagem which might just be to let him like it's
Flailing around so much oh i would okay let's see cover that cover that no? No, no, no
you don't want none of this you know what that nice yeah yeah the trick is
multi-surface bullshit not let it get off swamp gup-e
Back, off you back off you don't want none of this no, no, no
No, no, cover cover oh yeah you know ain't no nightmares here ain't no nightmares here ain't no nightmares. No, no
No, no, no i don't think so
No, i don't i don't i said i don't think so no you don't want those tutsis those cities are not, for you no
No, no, no, no not for you not for you
not, for you
Maybe it's just it is a good strategy to just keep them flailing nope that's definitely not a good strategy no, no, no
No, no these touches are off limit
the handy wendy is not for you randy okay that head muncher he's gonna be coming pretty soon
Of a funny feeling oh yeah there is no, no, no no just go i just got
To cover the face the top of the head and oh no worried about that now worried about that all right who are you
No, no, no, no no you guys go away you guys go away no, no, no no no no come on now
you're being ridiculous your favorite goddamn dick ulis with you're being ridiculous let's not wall away
okay all right there all right all right okay no i
Know i know oh that's problem no?
it's let's not do that let's let pussy patrol oh
I had the toy sorry
It's terrifying is tara i'm gonna do one more time i i don't think i'm gonna be able to get this out am
take some goddamn effort that's where they would stop being a goddamn weirdo
Every fucking time i think it pays, to make him go away
like all the way away i
Think there's there's some kind of better payoff
For that yeah the trick is to try to go for three you're never gonna cover all of it so?
when you can i guess go for three
Just, like basketball i think oh no, no
no, no, no that that that head covering is here way early whoa what the
good sailor
Well this just isn't fair that's is not fair that's obviously, uh, no?
not, the kiss ii wish ii don't give it kiss oh well all right that didn't work out at all
Okay all right that's enough of that one ha ha i am now i'm gonna be able to beat that one okay but if you
Wanna try that i highly recommended it is a challenge
all right welcome to planet of bloodthirsty
sins
if you remember
power drill massacre
This made by the same people oh boy
something's about to happen
Yeah, i don't know what then again i don't know what to expect in the game that's called
planet of bloodthirsty
Santa or why anyone would want to go to planet a bloodthirsty santa it's like
Futurama when santo is a horrible murderous robot but even worse
somehow whoa
Five active crew miss should collect the mineral or in unclaimed sectors of quadrant two scans from surface of?
Fnc 133 to for have returned with the high yield concentration of iron lithium and two presumably undiscovered minerals oh
we will be leaving comfortably for the rest of our lives
i've still got a bad feeling about this planet oh nonsense
it's completely uninhabited planet we'd fry david the scan didn't pick up any life-forms
Still it wouldn't hurt to bring some protection god damn it don't be silly bathe which is gonna do some quick reconnaissance
yes, would like the four minerals each and returned to the ship david you head west and all go north but
beth
i'm gonna tell you this just once but i wanna fucking hear from you to click four of those minerals
all so help me god beth i'm gonna bust you down from sink and officer so fast and i'm gonna know what she knew
capiche come on guys it's freezing out here let's get on with it okay
what a great wholesome team oh boy oh i'm playing now yep okay yeah this is very babysitter
Bloodbath and very much power drill massacre which way was i supposed to go i wasn't listening
To you being an asshole so i don't really wool
Also why were they, so much taller than me that didn't make a lot of sense
I can jump hey that's a that's a market improvement from what i was doing before whoo yeah whoo
Okay all right then where am i going oh this way oh, okay i found it i found the way
everybody follow me
to death or richness or aura busting down from second officer i
can definitely smell the bloodthirsty
santa and i don't know why
santa is bloodthirsty or why he lives on this planet all by himself but oh well
oh
That's weird a tree mmm, oh another tree that's oh the forest?
Okay that's a little odd why are there these things and what's that glowing up on the hill over there that's not good
Yeah, oh more true oh, oh candy cane that's bizarre i don't think that's right whoa
reminds me of a long time ago and i played this slenderman christmas special that was a goddamn delight a house wait
totally uninhabited planet but there's a
goddamn house here oh
No, can't do that what is the e button do oh checks over that shoulder i guess what's the point of that oh?
Ah that's normal okay just got, to follow the candy cane
We're gonna jump for it i think probably not but here oh?
jump, oh shit missed my jump well
okay.i
sorry i'll get back -
i'm sorry - pardon me
Pardon me sir okay
made it alright that was easy enough
Don't know what that's all about oh okay?
my favorite jams thank you for playing me some coldplay
whoa shit almost mess that up hello ding dong oh did not expect that to open
not, gonna lie also hello christmas tree o christmas
Tree who look i shiny
thingy i don't know how to pick you up oh found an out read it
dil has been gone for three days he thinks he can just work us at that tired and we won't notice that we notices though
i'm not gonna let him get away with this he thinks that
Thousand-yard stare and cold laugh is intimidating i'm going to his castle tonight sneak in if i have to this elf isn't gonna let
him roll over us that
dill
dill pickle from the rugrats
Who are we talking about here we're talking about santa saint dill saint nicholas
Now we're dying oh look a sack that's fun oh, no it's a ball sorry i always get my sax confused with my balls
It's i'm going up to santa's castle over there which is a new thing but a welcome thing to be sure?
Oh, is that us oh that's a snowman in it alright oh that's multiple snowman, ah?
Sorry where am i going llama gone oh that's not oh that's a sweeping oh that's not good?
okay i gotta make this jump apparently oh i guess
we go
Made it oh i guess i could have gone behind that okay so i'm guessing i shouldn't be seen by that thing
Oh, that's not good oh that's very scary okay all right well that's that's not good?
I'm wondering the same thing
okay i'm guessing i don't wanna be detected by
Wool boy boy boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy hmm okay go go go
Bud huh okay there's another sort of building up here i don't know what it is but let me see if i can get inside
Oh, good it's already pre broken down i was hoping for this
like like die or something this is a fever dreamers is for realsies oh look a note read it
Santa's constantly appearing in the village in the dead of night he stays somewhat quiet just wandering around the alleys i've seen him looking around
Peeking through windows following else home he's freaking us all the hell out i mean santa is the nicest guy he's never done any
boozing not that we've heard he may be acting strange but i know he'd never hurt us
if you say so
whatever you say
oh
Okay you're fine that's fine that's nothing it's just a cheapo jump-scare nothing i need to worry about
at all okay what is this okay never mind okay hang on gonna get up here angela this is really squeaks cuong carly
okay what's this found it's a fire pick it up
i
got a mineral boy my friends are gonna
who are you talking to yourself with let me squeaks wang kang on scootaloo doodly-doo just got a crab walk over here
okay
stop that what is that oh
All right whatever i got what i needed i think let me see if there's anything else here
Oh, where's that light oh?
there's that light okay well
um buff, i'll go this way then you don't get me don't get me get me
All right next house all right i love this, game oh?
Never mind can't go in that one
Can't go in that one?
it's gonna not go in the i'm i should know about this one up here is he special can this be gone in what can
it go oh that blood okay all right this ain't a good thing
is the opposite of a good thing
Hey look it's another mineral
found in turquoise
right
yep, almost there almost there baby almost there all right oh
well that's a sound
know, why that happened but i'm gonna ignore it and carry on with my life
but up
Ok sneaks nonk found a note all that's been missing ever since she went to santa's castle i don't know what we're supposed to assume
Kringle had has has had this
distance to everything he's said lately like he's not really talking to us of that makes sense
I'm worried that there's no real end of this but a debt wanted to go talk
To him figure something out i have no idea what i can do well
sounds like kris kringle went a little
crazy
Oh, why why would you do that to me why would you do that why don't do that
I'll do that lights over there i don't think there's anything else over here so i'm assuming it's time to try to
make my way to the castle i guess i couldn't go in this building there's another one over there i don't know i
Don't know i'm just trying to stay away from the light
whoa
Looks good enough to me whoa whoa wait whoa easy oh? Boy oh boy
oh
yi yi yi
okay, i'm in life okay i'm fine can i go in this building please tell me okay well if i could just stop power jumping
Okay if i could get it off okay i'll take the ramp bye
david
yeah, something is trying to kill us
we fuck yo what the fuck why were you talking about nicole
ferran is adding something everything he does is so
shifty, he knows something about this this shift in santa a few of us are planning a bit
Dialogue a bit of dialogue with him when he leaves the workshop tonight a few of us are going to get some answers
And that little smiley bastard is gonna give us the answers so long as we avoid santa's searchlights we should be fine
we can't forget that dill still hasn't come back since he was brought to santa
Farren probably knows something about that too i'm tired of waiting for answers from santa yeah me too baby me too i want
answers i guess
where's this sir sir oh
that's not good
yeah, well that's a problem
That's definitively a problem oh boy let's search like to stay in there okay okay okay oh?
No, it's just some red light oh just the town is bathed in blood oh these poor elves
okay i
Can't go in there i'm going
To santa i'm coming for you baby i'm coming for you i thought you could get away with all your murder oh?
Boys it's camping right this is backtracking how do we get to your goddamn whoa how do we get oh that's sweet oh?
The toy factory oh of course
How could i be so stupid
Guards i go to the toy bag oh this looks important
whatever that jolly red red fuck is crazy if he thinks we're gonna take this we've done nothing to loyal productive he just rolls right
ours every year bigger numbers shorter dates i'm starting to lose it this rate will be dead oh
okay can i okay no all right well a
problem problem problem problem problem
let me get let me fuck let me in oh shit oh fuck oh, oh
okay, i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i think i'm fine oh don't go that way okay well that didn't help anybody at all
How do we get into the toy factory i don't know
Huh, here we go whoa
okay i found one that was finally open well it's a good thing we split up to cover more ground and sure i'm happy that
I'm taking this on alone ooh that's an ominous red glow hey no great let's do it let's do this or not
There we go let's do this
without this fair and think he is the cheery little
flock he just keeps giving those fucking ridiculous orders same smile on his stupid face is he pretending that nothing is different
Hell he's the only one that even looks at us anymore
I think i've seen santa once this last month and i was in the dead of night
he was just standing in the square of the village just looking around i don't know what he's planning finally going senile
Have that's all this?
Hate that hate that hate that unruh be alright?
okay alright hurry okay thank you susan whoever that is no susan
So there's got, to be one more house that i haven't found yet
maybe i don't know
Whoa-oh-oh-oh-oh! What is happening i don't know what happening
don't like that
Huh!
okay i'm out of who jesus ja i'm out of there okay that's no good that's no good for anybody especially not me
not
Me in my sensitive supple body oh that's not good i don't know
Maybe i missed the very first house that came up maybe i could have gone in there and i didn't i don't know i don't
know man i'm really trying here
really trying was this was this way - oh that's right this doesn't
god can you oh my god can you stop
Please oh why why oh?
Come on oh fuck me okay okay here's the first house i was fucking locked all the time it was shit
oh
Wow oh why oh hi hello hi santa what are you doing here what the?
fucking fuck
Okay hi oh i don't think i want to give you any of my blood
where did you come from oh
my god he's still there okay still there
well i think actually i'm kind of going into a got into a bit of a
bit of a tight situation here i don't think there's any way out of this one
Kevin is locked up he's locked up and i'm locked up too okay here we go bleep fake bob
Okay made it alright he's probably very close by me but i didn't find my last
Thing, no, no, no
maybe that's what happened when i got spotted by the spotlight he's been waiting for me ever since
Know which is a bit of a problem but oh well what can you do i don't know where can i go i don't understand
oh
look maybe there's something like round the back edges of the
toy factory
Who oh, no he's stuck right there okay i see him i see you i see you friend okay oh hi whoa oh?
Whoa hi um okay it's gotta be something, to do with that toy factory right it's gotta be
It's gotta be something to do with the toy factory it's gotta be that's the only other place i haven't been?
and it seems so big and important that you think that it would be
something that's important i don't know why else would you be here
Why else would you be so big and important oh jesus oh this is not a good idea okay there i go well
fuck
Dude i don't even know oh where am i now huh i don't know oh well fucking
well i think i goofed that
there may be a way that i could like swing jump around i don't know if i could
um price still bone oh
Oh, oh oh oh oh what the fuck
Whoo i was just double-checking this place you don't need to come in here santa?
Huh, fuck off you don't need to do anything
well that's not good
all right i know i don't actually know where to go santa so you killing me and that i
Don't even know oh my god come on?
what happened
oh, i don't know okay well there's that then okay i
don't know what to do i'm i'm at a complete loss up and running around in circles i've checked back on every home i
thought i did i even jumped up on the roofs hoping that they would be like some
some kind of subtle entrance up here but it seems like that is a big ol
noboru knee i
can't make that jump
no i don't know man i
Don't know and i don't know where okay all right whoa what what what why?
what
What is what is that supposed to mean i don't even know what that is i don't even understand what you're trying to tell me
Are you just doing that to spook
Me why oh i don't know does that mean kris kringle is are coming cuz if he is that's that's no good
But at this point i don't know what else to do besides let him try to kill me oh there we go i guess
sure
whoa whoa
Okay well i ran out of lives i have no idea
What i was supposed to do there
But i died to santa and i think that's a sign so anyway i'll end that there if you guys want
To see if there's any more to that yeah i'll provide a link in the description below again it's i think it's just
A demo it's not, the full release of the game but these games are always very
fascinating to me because they're forcibly made in an old vhs like 80s style
like bloody horror it's a lot of fun so
thank you everybody someone for watching let me know what you thought down in the comments below
and as always, see you, in the next video. BUH-BYE!!